[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits I'm rich and I'm
link thanks for joining us again it is
another adventure at the roundtable of
dim lighting
I've never get an adventure this visit
adventure but I thought I would forewarn
you this week's episode of a sighted
well you weren't excited well I was
mildly excited but now I'm really
excited it's adventure an adventure do I
need like a Camelback or something yeah
you need to be constantly hydrated on
this thing the interesting person from
the internet that we're talking to this
week is the one and only Felicia Day
she's not only famous for having red
hair which maybe she's not famous for
that
well she has red hair okay that's that's
one thing she's also known for her
acting on Buffy the Vampire Slayer and
supernatural and as penny on dr.
Horrible's sing-along blog one of my
favorites among many other things but
she's more than just an actor oh yeah
she's done a lot of stuff in the the web
space I think probably one of the most
successful web series ever you know
going back years ago six seasons of the
guild I know you've heard of the guild
this is about the online gamers guild
called the Knights of good who played
countless hours of a fantasy MMORPG
called the game that she wrote this she
produced it she was in it I mean she
basically this is her baby the guild
here's a clip
there's a saying keep your friends close
but your enemies closer right can I
change that to the closer your friends
come the more they look like enemies I
mean come on
first tink steals my server cave and
Zabu moves into my work I was so dumb to
think I could keep the game and the
guild separate even for a day and then
when they mix it's like oil and water
fire and gasoline nuclear Dragon and
fairy toadstool village doesn't know
what she's got weird quick so the guild
ended its sixth season run in January of
2013 garnering well over a hundred
million views and I mean that's a lot I
mean considering how difficult it is to
create for narrative narrative content
on YouTube Felicia also co-founded
YouTube channel geek and sundry and is
continuously creating quality geek and
gamer centered content for you on the
will and our latest project
called spooked it's a she executive
produced this and it's being called a
cross between the Ghostbusters and the
guild highly-anticipated it's on Hulu
and it's also on the geek and sundry
YouTube channel and you said that
Ghostbusters but the movies are just
called ghosts did I say that ghost you
said it so well my money [ __ ]
Ghostbusters like three guys yeah yeah I
think as the three guys it's a team of
paranormal detective so it is the like
the Ghostbusters and the guild people
yeah we'll go there's nothing wrong with
what I said okay we had a great
conversation with Felicia we touched on
lots of topics including growing up as a
home-schooled misfit in the deep south
the circumstances that led to her
writing the guild her thoughts on
misogyny in geek culture how she deals
with trolls and we talked about kissing
girls on screen plus much more so here
it is area biscuit with Felicia Day well
you got to pretend but your fork is in
your hand you're like you talk about
saying grace yeah we're recording and I
think we should start by saying grace
okay they do it in their head they won't
say it out loud because then it's like
I'm saying grace and I don't want to
make a demonstration of it sooner to
kind of like awkwardly like what should
I be doing in my head while you're
praying to whatever God you pray to
right and they could just be having some
sort of fit or like don't eat too much
like somehow the internals like don't
eat all those potatoes talk a pep talk
yeah it is kind of weird because it's in
you they're basically saying I want you
to be a part of something that I'm doing
without you yes so it's this it put you
on the spot to come up with something to
do while they're doing their think
silent like silently praying their lips
are moving a little bit is that what you
mean yeah that's what I mean but then
they don't want to impose on you they're
not like hey can we please say grace
because that feels like they're imposing
the religion on you and yet they need
their moment to say grace while you're
in the middle of a conversation so they
start
so it is imposing it is imposing cuz
they're stopping everything to say grace
which is fine but then as me as a
non-religious person I'm will already
dug into my macaroni and I'm like well
should I stop chewing should I just slow
down should I stare at you maybe you
should just continue eating I mean maybe
that would be that's the natural thing I
never want to do it always feels awkward
well let me ask you what have you done
and have you have you landed on a
technique well one time I bowed my head
for your stander yeah a bystander exact
prayer standard that's true I bowed my
head once and I was like this is stupid
I'm not talking to anyone you know so
then that felt false cuz then I'm like
well I'm pretending to pray to a god
they're gonna get pissed off that I'm a
poser I'd rather just not do anything so
then I meaning the gods are gonna get
pissed off
whoever's anywhere or your friend I
think you know the person who is being
prayed to or the entity ah because their
lies are clothes they're in their own
things right right and then then I I
stopped awkwardly you know so soon you
either join in which was not I wasn't
doing it it was just posing right and
then to just keep eating which feels
dickish and then three it's just kind of
like a mid to stop like let's pause like
literally like I'm frozen that's not the
freeze that face and you seen you look
off you seem to not be looking at like
if I was the prayer yeah you would I
would look down who looked down imitate
them so it's gonna have a half pray but
your eyes are open it's a half pray it's
really just evaluating what I ordered
yeah like planning your first bite yes I
mean you just take I mean you could just
take a moment of silence for what 911
just for you know just to center
yourself you know just to be like
alright this person is praying I'm just
going to take a moment of silence you
know or you could just break your phone
out no that's the word that would be the
worst that would be the room okay they
just do the moment of something little
silence maybe I do have a meditation app
on my phone yeah so I could break out
whatever it is I listen to there when
I'm doing it which I'd usually don't get
around to it but it's on my to-do list
every day no but I would think that
growing up in Alabama
oh you wikipedia'd me Oh II do that
Wikipedia it goes much deeper yeah this
is something that you've dealt with you
dealt with growing up I mean surely
there was less people saying grace
around you in Alabama not well yeah I
went to religious school for a couple
years but then we moved to Mississippi
which is even more pretty yeah but Ray I
know but then I did not go to school
there I was home-schooled cuz my mom was
this hippie and she was like these the
school system is horrible and I don't
want you to go so just don't go
so what we're in Mississippi and what
age did you move there Ocean Springs
Mississippi I moved there when I was I
believe 7-7 I lived there until I was
about 13 is that near the coast it's all
the coast is Renison Springs because my
dad was stationed at Keesler Air Force
Base okay
yeah so that's why I moved there and it
was such a bad school system I guess it
was like ranked lowest in the country
when we moved my mom was like you're not
we're not having this there were other
options that she could have done versus
just keeping us at home I mean perfectly
valid ones but at the time I didn't know
that she was I was like hey we're never
going to school again no I mean right
described hippie mom in more detail um
you know she we recycled before it was
cool we were Greenpeace t-shirts we it
was almost not even possible to recycle
in Mississippi it was not we had to
drive an hour away to take our bottle it
just meant using your own bottles again
yeah yeah but you're being serious you
had to drive over an hour in order to
recycle yes yeah it was like I think it
was even on the Alabama border or
something I mean she it was hardcore
guys and it's fine I mean like I'm I'm
kind of a hippie as well I don't I mean
we can recycle in a bin now it's
fantastic but this was this was hipster
pericyclic you know it reminds me of a
story we had a friend who is from
Alabama who moved out here and there as
a husband and wife they're both from
there and the wife's mother came to
visit them and they've been out in
California for you know a couple months
and they were recycling
and she was like I am I'm concerned
about y'all y'all are liberals be
because you're recycling yeah so we went
black we understand the it can be
difficult to find a place to take your
recycling it's true well you grew up in
the south and you just don't have the
context that you should in life I think
I mean I did not know the Jewish people
had their own foods until I moved to LA
and I was like what is this deli thing I
thought bagels were only frozen and I
honestly honestly honestly thought that
oh yeah me too yes absolutely anything
else but a frozen bagel no no I know I I
am not lying when I tell you I didn't
even know what a bagel was until college
yeah I mean seriously no there's no
diversity there's no representation
outside and I thought that it walks on a
bagel where it had to do with like not
being able to get it out of the freezer
I still don't know what you're talking
about
LOX ello ex he's still very much of a
redneck
a smoked fish saltier than a smoked say
I kind of pretty good in the moment Joe
sorry about that
as a result when I moved to LA I went to
every single deli in Southern California
and had matzo-ball soup because I
thought it was literally the best
invention known to man it's a soup and
bread at the same time it's Fenske all
stick soggy bread question mark well
yeah
being homeschooled and in the South with
the hippie mom who wanted to take you
out of the school system and things like
that and kind of had a different
perspective on things
even within home schooling I would
assume in the South you were isolated
because there were home there were there
was a homeschool contingent but that was
also a religious crazy religion those
were like the girls who were hair shirts
and we tried to socialize with them a
couple times right there was just no
connection there hair shirts you know
like it was so religious that they had
to wear dresses down to their ankles and
they had to wear like button-up white
shirts that kind of cuffed at their
notes showing no skin basically the
Christian equivalent of a Burke
a lot of these kids down there right
were raised as and that was there was no
connection there anyway either right so
you were taken out of the public school
but then you wouldn't you the little
homeschool gatherings that you could
have had we had a couple we were like no
we're not going back no so who'd you
hang out with nobody brothers and
sisters I had a younger brother I have
have I have another sorry Ryan yeah
still around around around yeah we
actually ever showed together
co-optitude he's out huh every month and
we recorded together but yeah me and my
brother hung out together in general I
just had a lot of lessons so I would I
would not hang out with the kids at
lessons but I would be around them at
lessons and I also did theater and what
kind of lessons we talking about violin
dance karate we combine those three I
could because then it would be like
Lindsey Stirling plus one plus one
Lindsey Stirling plus martial arts no
she she could do you you could cut to
her like just using a violin as a weapon
like is it oh you can poke a mean eye
out with a violin it's poker you can get
yeah I actually saw that happen almost
happen it went at the Largo I was
telling you about us the Sara Watkins
thing and she was playing the violin and
her brother leaned down and she got this
close to and nobody noticed it except me
ie there was no gasping I was like she
almost put it out with a bow there's
nothing worse I got poked in the eye but
by a girl when I was six that was with
what with her finger her colon you felt
it go all the way it went all the way
and I had to wear a patch for six months
I did that to my grandma did you do this
your crew yeah I was about six years old
and I poked my nanny in the eye and she
had to wear a patch for like six months
and I would go there every Sunday to eat
fried chicken and I feel horrible
there she is old eyepatch Nana I mean
she regained her sight but how did they
send them with you I was on the tires
and it was just she was balancing
herself and she had pointy fingers and I
just I got an eye balls reach of her
Jennifer I always remember Jennifer
Jennifer and that finger yeah there was
no there's no more pain there's no
greater pain I've never given birth but
I assume that there could be no greater
pain than gain your eyes
yeah like that I mean she scratched my
cornea
like really bad was there permanent
damage if I could find her now on
Facebook I'd I'd tell her something what
would you tell her just saying I mean
Jennifer just for the record you ruined
my first grade the only grade I ever
went to school thank you well you were
the pirate I was a pirate and I did not
like pirates did you or a fashionable
eyepatch it is the black hole it was it
was like it was it was it was kind of
like a cream color with with a medal it
was not even nobody even bothered
decorating it for me because you could
have done just like some sort of head
scarf that just happened to go over one
eye that's what I'll assure if I had to
do an eyepatch that's what I would do
you really it would be a bandana that
went over one eye or a hairstyle like
Aaliyah she only had one eye
she's dead that's why she died she died
of black oven I didn't she died in a
plane crash or oh no she died in a car
crash in Honduras because I was in
Honduras music let's just stick to that
yeah there's a perception joke in there
somewhere but I'm not gonna make it
because she's dead right okay or she's
not who knows boy so how did you deal as
a young Felicia with these things did
you did you pour yourself into the
violin I did I just decided to be as
good as I could at all the things that I
actually had came in contact with and I
just really liked the violin it was good
it was good to spend some hours doing
that and at the same time I did I did
dance I dance like three four hours a
day I wanted to be a dancer actually
that was belly yellow yeah ballet tap I
took all of them and I did a lot of like
musical theater so I specialized in me
like the fifth orphan from the back or
like the can-can girl in Oklahoma you
know I never had major parts but I
always liked the supporting player and
just being around people in the theater
is fun you know it's make making you're
making something together even if you're
a small part you're part of the whole
and that was me this is theatre in
Mississippi yeah so what's the nearest
town that you were relaxing okay so you
were outside of me yeah and there
actually were a lot of people who there
were really into theater you
they would they're people who moved back
from New York who just came home to do
stuff so I think anywhere you go you can
do see it and that's what I always tell
people if they want to be an actor I'm
like stay home get a lot of experience
under your belt where you are first cuz
you don't just be going on a boat you
know get on a boat or a bus to LA and
just saying hey tada
discover me because I did that and it
took a long time to figure it out but a
lot of people just you know do that
which is not the smartest so you were
the background Theater but I would have
thought that she would have kind of
moved into you know that starring role
type of thing that didn't happen well I
was so young I was like 14 you know what
the oldest was 14 or 15 when I was doing
these things so it was generally adults
who had the starring parts I was like
the sister in Brigadoon I was like one
of the prostitutes and Sweet Charity
like three times you know so it was your
dad was in the Air Force and was your
mom basically spending most of her time
you know teaching you guys and that kind
of thing does she have something she was
also doing as because I mean our wives
Helms Clark kids so oh yeah I know for a
fact that that is a full-time job
it is a full-time job my mom was pretty
lenient and that we never did tests or
anything you know I kind of just taught
myself every I would I had a schedule
that I adhered to that I made up myself
that was pretty much it educated me so
she was you know she always had well the
one thing I will say is that she was we
had resources available to us in every
single subject we were always buying
books and I've read thousands and
thousands of books as a kid because I'm
not doing anything else except sitting
around the house right and this is
before Netflix and that we just educate
our kids with Netflix no I wish if I if
your wife could educate me I would have
a much different childhood yeah no but
but I had a very regimented schedule and
my grandpa really loved
he was physicists a nuclear physicist so
he was really impressed when I knew math
proofs so I put a lot of effort into my
violin and math Bruce only because it
tended to impress people and I got
rewarded for that and it just kind of
and I enjoyed it
nuclear physicist so and he's your
grandfather so is he like involved in
the development of like the laser the
laser yeah I was gonna say like
the atomic bomb well then the national
defense systems all that Star Wars stuff
he was really high up and all that
during the 80s and stuff like that so
you know he like helped invent real
lasers that are used this is faceted I
know he was a great guy he passed away
several years ago but he has like
hundreds of patents in his name so so
your proclivity to math was to gain his
approval yeah kind of but also I enjoyed
it I liked you know not on a problem in
my head and and and it was something my
mom couldn't do so she encouraged me she
was like you impressed grandpa because I
could never do it was the you know with
being so musical and then like enjoying
math being into that which informed the
other did you see music as from a
mathematical standpoint well even for us
with engineering degrees I think a lot
of times when we're creating things we
see if from a mathematical standpoint
there's a problem to be solved well
there needs to be a joke here it's kind
of like arriving at a solution yeah no
actually I did a video on my personal
channel last week about producing
because I feel like people are really
impressed when I'm an actor but actually
I do a lot of my time is producing and
making things behind the scenes and I'm
in an analogy about a math degree coming
in handy when you're trying to produce
something well because you have an end
result like a proof they are trying to
use the tools that you have to put
together and make the M result happen
correctly right and that is the same as
filmmaking really I mean you have a
goalie of a script or you know project
and you have to look around you and say
hey what tools do I have to put this
together to realize this end you know
and result and yeah I definitely think
there's no mathematics there's a music
to comedy especially I think you know
I'm pretty you know in the guild
specifically I was really precise about
how people not rewrite my lines and
stuff sometimes people that have the
better alternatives but in general was
very strict about say it the way I wrote
it because there was a music in my own
head that ending to sing in my ear if
they've changed it it wasn't as
me appealing it was just a control freak
it's also called a control freak yeah
well that's gonna be a good quality so
even in terms of like the rhythm of it
like oh you didn't say that when I wrote
this line I heard it being delivered
kind of in this rhythm sometimes to that
extent sometimes people wouldn't get the
intent I mean yeah I mean obviously I
know people aren't in cages in their own
individually out their own individual
elodie comes to the forefront and when
you're reading dialog as an actor but
sometimes they wouldn't get the
intention of it I mean only rarely have
have I have I said like okay just say it
like this but usually when you tell an
actor okay the intention here is to do
this then they get it and they know how
to read the line or say it so but there
is I think there's a certain rhythm to
make especially comedy work because it's
really all about timing hmm yeah so you
see that music and math kind of
influence different things the music
maybe in your writing the math and your
producing yeah yes and and also I did a
thesis paper on this but music and math
are generally because you're double
majoring in mathematics and music and
there is a there's a correlation between
the area of the brain that deals with
music especially classical music and
mathematics theoretical mathematics
right there is a lot of overlap there so
you're involved in performance you're
doing the theater thing and the music
thing you then you go off to Texas
double major in music and mathematics at
that point when you when you made the
decision to go to Texas what were you
thinking well my dad moved there he was
a sign there we moved like oh well when
I was like 13 we moved like eight times
oh and two owners basically so there's a
lot of moving around when he was going
to finish off his medical research and
stuff well and our light just came back
I know we are our dimmed lighting failed
so he had to go at alternate lighting
but then the dim light he came back well
now it's even more on being here yeah so
but you turned down an opportunity to go
to Juilliard right yeah so I was
disgusted I was accepted to pre-program
for Julliard which is basically a feeder
program to go into Juilliard so you know
partially I was accepted to
but it was very it's on the weekend so
basically go on the weekends for like a
year or two before Julliard and then you
know that's a fast track to get into
Julliard and we couldn't afford to live
in New York City and my dad couldn't get
stationed anywhere around so it would
have been prohibitively expensive for us
to have to house while we were I mean
listen I grew up very poor really cuz
the lessons basically took all the money
so we never really had a new couch ever
you know I only got my clothes from
Goodwill like we were not poor I mean we
were poor in that sense but we always my
mom always had the best people tutoring
us so it was kind of you know those
choir and I think those priorities like
definitely stick with me
yeah you know so yeah I unfortunately
couldn't do that but I got a full
scholarship to go to University of Texas
because my professor taught there and he
was like hey you wanna go to college and
I was like sure I'm 15 let's get out of
here also you went at 15 I just turned
16 he got me the scholarship when I was
15 it was full ride I never here is it
here's a fun fact I didn't know I have a
high school diploma I never need them a
high school diploma but I have two
degrees two college degrees and I don't
know actually if that's legal anymore
like I don't know if it's legal you
shouldn't have shared that because
they're gonna invalidate so they can
just take it away yeah and then you know
what you're gonna have degrees anymore
and your whole life is gonna fall apart
because you know what happens to be boo
don't have college degrees you can just
hang out here if you want I mean I like
it it's a pretty cool room especially
with the lights back on yeah albeit like
we weren't into Tariq we just had the
light of we were just feeling each other
like okay you go yeah like just our eyes
are wide open can see anything sensory
deprivation in here
okay so then acting I mean you've got
the music thing you got the math thing
what were you thinking that you wanted
to do and then how did his switch I
always knew I wouldn't be an actor okay
and I was got on the bus and left that's
why I was telling you earlier don't do
what I did because I had no
qualifications I got my degrees because
my parents said I had to get degrees
okay um I got the mastery because my dad
was like you need to get a real degree
if you're gonna go to LA and I was like
sure here's a 4.0 dad
boom out of here and I don't know if
that was the smartest thing to do but
it's what I did and I did volunteer for
film festivals a lot so I I got a taste
of the business of Hollywood what was
what was college like as a 16 year old
it was not anybody else's college like
so basically I took 18 hours a semester
I mean I took I took I probably have
like 250 hours and you only need like
110 to graduate so like I have to 250
hours of college under my belt because
that makes sense if you didn't even want
to do it I did because though I liked it
I sure the achiever I'm an achiever I
love doing things I love studying I
actually you know my my dream would be
to go and I would I would love to go to
UCLA and get like a poetry degree or
like a history degree you know though
that would be truly if I just won five
million dollars tomorrow I'm I might I
would still make it be making film but I
would also be like hey I'm getting a
graduate degree in romantic poetry would
you like to talk about like specifically
Romantic poets I would yes that one I
would start with and then I go was like
ancient Greek you know lifestyle like I
like to see how people lived this is all
over the place anywho oh my dear
but I was nobody would invite me
anywhere because I was illegal I
couldn't drive my mom drove me to
college every day so you know it was not
any con it was not a real experience as
far as like anybody else's experience
which he lived at home yeah I lived out
but Austin was significantly different
than Biloxi miss no it was great like I
said I have Olinger for film festivals I
knew I wanted to get into the film
business because I like theater but I
wanted to be on film as an actor and my
ex I did a little student film here and
there but mostly my experience came from
volunteering for film festivals and that
was kind of like the height of the indie
you know film world that was when
Sundance was really about the work
versus like parties and just being in
that environment made me more excited to
be there because it seemed like this
rebellious you know I only saw the indie
side of Hollywood so I'm like oh my god
people are out of the box they're
creating things they're making people
think differently this is what I want to
be part of so that was your passion
that's where you wanted to go yeah was
it just because you're wired as an
achiever or was there also something
that personally happened in your life
that kind of drove you to prove yourself
was
any naysayers growing up family friends
anything like that anyone besides
Jennifer poking you in the eye to say
I've got to this is all for Jennifer you
said I can't do it so I'm going to I
think that yeah that comes into play
more when I'm in Hollywood
I grew up sort of in a vacuum I didn't
know how people acted I didn't know how
girls were supposed to be I didn't know
anything but the sort of books and what
I saw in lessons which is all about
being the best you can be at something
specific so I think that's what drew
drove me the most is just achievement
because I loved learning and I loved you
know I got along better with my
professors unlike my colleague you know
my co students you know so you earned
the right to go to LA and that's what
you did yeah absolutely and I'd you do
that exactly drivers you had won by then
no I were you I was I am in today at 220
I was at 2021
so after a full four years in it was
four it was five years actually so it
just turned 21 when I graduated or I was
just about to turn 21 so I knew a lot of
people from the film festival so I did
know a lot of people so at least I had a
little bit of an entree there into that
world so and I admit some you know I'd
done some acting in Austin so I had a
couple connections to get you know an
agent or an idea of an agent or at least
the idea knowing what to do I I've met
some actors who are like hey you should
do this and get in this class in the
blah blah blah so I didn't go completely
blind I did have somewhat of a little
bit of a support system through the film
festival circuit and some other actors
but it was it was pretty like whoa this
is here you are right and so what was
the first thing that you did to make
money well I had saved a lot of money
because I was a professional musician
during college so I was one of the
youngest people ever to join the Austin
Symphony I I did weddings every single
weekend so I made hundreds and hundred
dollars every silent for hire yeah
basically which one a bit I could still
be doing that I have friends in Austin
who still do that
there are freelance musicians and they
make a great living and I could still be
doing that and I did a little bit of
that
but basically the savings until I got a
bunch of commercials you know I lived
off my savings and I had saved you know
I lived at home I had no expenses I had
full scholarship so I saved every single
penny and I was able to live for like a
year and a half almost two years just on
that what was that first commercial oh
my god my first commercial was a
starburst commercial and I got hired
even though the director said in front
of somebody she's too white to hire that
was literally because it was a summer
commercial and he was saying why is she
so pale
albino get this albino out of here well
did she say did he say white pale or
albino um he said I'll buy no on the set
because he's like take a light off that
albino I will never forget that oh wow
and then in the fitting she's like so
she's so pale why do they make me hire
her you know he literally said that to
somebody next and I'm like I'm and
that's quite an introduction to
Hollywood oh it was brutal like it was a
wake-up call because I was always a
teacher's pet you know my whole life and
then it's just like I don't understand
why you don't love me everybody does I'm
you know but acting is not about your
how hard you work it's there's a lot of
other things that go into it which was
the biggest probably learning curve that
I had but um but you I mean you are in
fairness you're kind of pale I mean
let's just on that it's I own it I am
the palest person ever I always have
pale offs you know like oh that's a piss
excuse me sir can you just oh yeah I I
am waiting for someone to cast me as a
ghost because every time I work on a set
the I can see the DP take a light off me
from the stand-in you know when you're
on a TV show they have a stand and sit
for you and then when I come into the
shot and sit down so they can look they
always take a light off and I'm like if
I'm glowing so good somebody hire me to
be a dead person the DP brings the light
meter up to unit like cracks yeah crap
well I mean you can play a ghost I mean
you're producing this series oh it's
true well if we it's already shot if we
start funding for more episodes yes I
will write myself in as something that
glows legit so that was the first
experience and then no but I didn't tell
you I got cut out of the commercial oh
you weren't even in it yeah they told me
when it was gonna be on it was like
11:15 p.m. on MTV you know
all my family I'm like I finally got a
real job everybody and we sat there and
watched it and I was not in it and I did
not understand I even called the next
day I was like so what happened they're
like this is what happens they cut you
out of things so what did you do in the
commercial that you weren't in i sat in
a beet a lawn chair and I went I'm rich
that's it understand in that voice
I didn't sort of gretagard I'm rich no I
just said it was like some kind of
sweepstakes where everybody got and I'm
like what it what did one of the kids do
with their money yeah and I was like I'm
rich I was on the beach I mean
legitimately I do not look like I should
be on a beach well but that's that's
where the tan starts never that's where
the burn happens I would just burn I
would just explode like a devil did it
get was that a low point or did it get
lower before Buffy the Vampire Slayer
whatever the big break was you know I've
had many low points in in acting oh how
many I you know I cut my hair off and I
started working it was like an instant
switch once I stuck cut my hair off
people are like oh that flippy flippy
hair bobbed girl I like her so I did
start getting a lot of commercials and I
those things can pay crazy money
especially back then you know ten years
ago it was like you could make a year in
a day you're just worth a pay any day
which I did what was the big one that I
saw you in I was actually I was actually
a post office represent I was a girl
named Angie and I did one and I was kind
of this frantic secretary girl and they
liked me so much they wrote me like a
campaign it wasn't a huge campaign but
we did for commercials and people would
recognize me because they ran all the
time on TV and that was like I got all
my bills paid thank you yeah Thank You
Hollywood and it was fun it was a cute
little spot so I tended to work a lot in
commercials and then I randomly went an
audition for Buffy the Vampire Slayer
and as the guest star for the episode
and they liked me a lot and they had me
go out and read some sides that they had
just
written which is always my best when I
don't over prepare and they called me
the next day and hired me for an Asian
girl part so interesting the car the
part that I actually got hired for was
supposed to be an Asian girl I'm sorry
whatever Asian girls have a job away
from is that what it like said in the
script it did say in the script live I
was an Asian girl and then it was
changed to albino albino yeah okay so
what you know you you've got this you
have a brand obviously now you know ten
years later after breaking in and doing
these commercials and you you are the
Felicia Day that that you are now you
know with the the geek cred and all that
comes with it when you were starting
this acting career in going out and
auditioning for Buffy the Vampire Slayer
did you have something in mind like I'm
going to be this kind of actress or was
it just like I just want a job as an
actress did you have a vision I didn't
know I don't think I had a vision I I
found out that I enjoyed comedy after I
started taking improv classes here which
I did it didn't occur to me I wanted to
be like an indie film actor when I first
moved here cuz that's the world I knew
and then when I and I realized I had to
be really weepy and probably was just
like the victim of the week I played a
couple of those like hey I was assaulted
and hey my friend died and I'm just in a
our show and just get one scene I was
like this is not great I don't like this
and then I started doing comedy and I
loved it so much better I mean and I
didn't even occur to me that I was good
at it so I took classes and through
doing that I started getting comedy work
which you know at the time I would test
for a lot of pilots that became big
later and I was always like second
choice you know like what um God there
were a couple of WB shows that um I mean
I sit for like this show called him
Samantha who a bunch of comedies that
didn't go but were pretty high-profile
so I would test for pilots three or four
you know times a year during that kind
of four years that I was really just
being an actor and getting a lot of
momentum behind that so so but but it's
so in my mind I wanted to be a half-hour
you know comedy actress because I really
enjoyed improv so those are the classes
that you're talking about you started
taking improv
classes and then I took a sketch writing
classes later to kind of fill my time so
it was fun you know you know I didn't I
don't think I had a solid idea of what I
wanted to do I just wanted to be in the
industry I think a lot of people move
here with that so that's why when I say
stay and figure out who you are it'll be
so much easier because if you let
everybody else define you that was kind
of my problem I started being defined as
like this flippy haired secretary and it
wasn't what I felt who I was inside and
I was adopting this attitude that I was
like I could work like this for 20 years
and I'd hate myself at the end of it and
so I was you know I that was one of the
reasons why I kind of started along the
path that I did to kind of rebel against
being pigeon-holed because I didn't
define myself before I got here I let
other people define what they wanted to
hire me as mm-hmm and where when did the
guild enter the picture how did that
come about um so I always play video
games on my life that's one thing that
my brother and I did the past time and
this is when you move into the thing
that a lot of people ask right I imagine
people want to know that guild origin
story yeah yeah and you know it's been
told before but you know you can always
tell it it's a lot of people haven't
heard it and I think it's a good story
for anyone oh I want to hear it yeah I
don't I don't I want you to believe hear
it in pig latin
okay pig latin I want to hear the dark
underbelly of it you mean the dark
underbelly was that I became addicted to
World of Warcraft for two years and I
and I start stopped going to auditions
and I stopped well going to classes and
I would literally play not kidding like
morning tonight I would sit there and
just play 12 hours a day eight hours a
day every single day was programmed
because I was supposed to be on line
with people you know I took over my life
because what I was doing as an actor you
know I would get enough work to pay all
my bills great but I wasn't busy
I wasn't challenged and I was being
defined in a way that I didn't like and
I didn't know how to take control back
so I basically just put it into becoming
the best warlock that I could be and
that was you know that was the hard part
and after a while I was I had you know
friends and they were like you need to
stop there was an intervention there was
a little bit of an intervention yeah
take place within
world of work because that would be one
way to do it no I think the guild fell
apart and that kind of helped the
grading guild that I was in fell apart
and then I was like I'm so shattered I
have no friends left I was like wait a
second
you know so that's when I decided to
write something because everybody had
been saying write something and take
control of your life and I'd never I
didn't have a clue as to what to write
before but once that's I sort of step
back from that experience I was like
well I know something that people don't
know about gamers and I don't think that
people have a accurate view of gamers
and I'd like to show them and I can
write a part that's perfect for me
that's a little bit autobiographical but
not completely and I could put it in a
half hour and Hollywood will just come
running so good plan you know right I'm
so smart right now so that's what I did
I wrote it in 2006 and was it easy to
write I don't hate you it wasn't
are you I mean you guys are writers you
know how hard the bright I mean you have
each other which is nice so you can't
allow each other to get stuck in the
mire of creative torment which I love
being in I just love it it's great
I'd say we're very intrigued about this
specifically because we want to write
long-form narrative content but we
haven't done that yeah it's hard it's
it's difficult and you know it's it
requires a quietness in your life
creatively in order to sort of gather it
all up and to reinterpret it as a role
had you even written anything was this
like the first thing you just sat down
to write I had written sketches so I've
been doing sketch comedy at Acme theatre
but other than that no I'd never written
III just attempted a couple of indie
films which are terrible but um I don't
even know if I had finished but one of
them and it was very bad so I put that
away for a while and no so the guild was
the only half-hour I wrote it as a
half-hour TV show okay and I was
literally the first time I'd ever
written anything but you know so you
just wrote a pilot I wrote a pilot yeah
but I had spent eight months just
working on who the characters were kind
of trying to distill you know cuz I had
been online for you know since I was a
little kid because my grandfather was
very technologically advanced so we were
always online even
before there was any internet at all he
was work logging on to the pre-internet
ERP and you know all that stuff to
operate a laser in space exactly the
other scientists used I mean that's
where the internet came from so my
parents knew about that and they always
had like online stuff and so I always
knew that you can connect with other
people on the internet and I was always
on whatever service it was you can
connect online even through college cuz
you can you could login through you you
know use Usenet and talk to people this
is like really olden times guys I'm
looking for a mom the Internet you have
to dial up and it went so then you took
the pilot on a traditional tour of yes
the TV lab right I did I showed it to
anybody fancy I knew and they were like
you are obviously a great writer you
need to be on staff somewhere you're
you're you know character really well I
don't know what the hell you're talking
about so they this was so early people
didn't have Twitter like this there was
myspace but it was more like you know
for for those MySpace people you know it
was not a mainstream situation and
gaming was even farther afield
yeah well that's it you know that's one
of the just the things that I've been
thinking as you talk about it in the
time that this happened is that did you
have a sense of how forward-thinking
this this idea was I mean now we you
know today 2014 we look we're in this
time where everybody wants to do
something that's got some tie-in to
gaming or comic books or whatever and
you were doing something that no one was
doing no it was very early it was early
early internet it was early gaming but
it didn't sound calculated it sound like
you were just expressing what you knew
and had an an unhealthy relationship
with yeah no I wanted to show I wanted
to represent and I think at the core of
it I wanted to show people that gamers
were not just you know overweight dudes
in their mom's basement being [ __ ]
like it was super important to me and I
wanted to show people what I knew about
gaming and feature the kind of people
who I knew gamed who are older men and a
mom
and you know young you know hostile
college girls you know there was there's
such a breadth to gaming that was
reflected in our world and especially I
didn't feel like anybody even recognize
the fact that women game or looking game
together but nobody spoke your language
so then what well they were like I don't
understand this I don't understand how
people talk to each other over gaming I
mean even today people are don't get it
so I was discouraged and then a friend
of mine who taught me my sketch class
Kim evey who you guys did very well she
read the script and was like hey my
husband and I have been doing sketches
for you this thing called YouTube and
YouTube started in 2006 as we all know
and this was literally January 2007
she's like we've been doing sketches and
I had one go viral her gorgeous tiny
chicken machine show and I think you
should make this for the web and I was
like great help me mm-hmm so we just
decided to shoot the first 10 pages and
that became three episodes and we did it
on her own dime and we did it for no
money almost and in our garage because
we were like so excited to take control
of our careers and just have fun I mean
there was no ulterior motive other than
enthusiasm what was the initial reaction
I'm trying to figure out exactly when
people stopped thinking this way on
YouTube what was there an initial
reaction that they were hoped it was
real and not scripted did you get to
bypass that because it was obvious I
think it was pretty obvious I think it
was I don't remember people being
confused about it being real or not but
the fact that codex I chose to write the
write the show with codex talking to the
camera
I think created that connection I think
without that it wouldn't have been as
big a hit and it was only in
construction I just thought hey this
looks amusing this this is something I
would watch yeah and I like this
connection with the audience that I
think lonely girl had just popped right
around there and I was like hey I like
this talking to the camera saying and I
I'm an internal person anyway and I want
to talk about an introverted person and
it's hard to write because they're not
proactive and the audience doesn't like
them but this is a window into the mind
of a character
that you can start every episode with so
I don't think anybody thought it was not
uh they mostly people are like I have a
work in my guild and I have a Claire of
my girl then and through my hard work
basically sitting on the computer 18
hours a day just posting it everyone the
internet like that's how the show gained
momentum and how did you how did you
know it was working beyond just you knew
it was good one person liked it I mean
it was really it like when I first saw
those comments go up I think we all
wanted to become a TV show we're like
hey we're gonna see this and it's gonna
be great and they're gonna be a TV show
but once that happened I was like screw
TV people like my stuff I've knew this
in my garage and they like it and I
don't care if it's ten people this is
the best thing you've ever watched and I
will sit here another ten hours and I
will email another hundred and fifty
people personally to please watch my
show and that is literally how the guild
happened it was not an overnight success
we didn't have a million views overnight
basically we we released one of months
for the whole first season and that was
ten months so nobody would do that with
a show now I don't know if you could do
it now because there's just too many
things distracting people but at the
time it allowed the show to spread word
of mouth and grow and my you know the
hard work that I did basically sitting
there emailing bloggers personally but
in every forum personally thanking every
single person who featured the show
personally on every single website like
that went a long way and you know we
funded the whole first season with a
PayPal button this was before
Kickstarter was invented we had put a
PayPal button up there after the first
three because I don't have the money to
have fund anymore and either at Kym and
surprisingly people donated and we got
enough to finish a whole season so it
was crowdfunding like the earliest kind
yeah and it was so gratifying and to me
that connection with the audience and
the material the fact that I was sharing
something that I felt needed to be
recognized and people were responding to
it hey I haven't seen a girl gamer but I
know a bunch like that was important to
me have you been surprised that you know
thinking about how early the series was
and how successful it was YouTube hasn't
really become a place where there are
a lot of great web series narrative
series to watch you know there are still
there are some but that's not really
what defines YouTube even now it's it's
still a lot a lot of vloggers you're
just flogging not as part of a series
but just vlogging yeah and a lot of
one-off videos and that kind of thing
mm-hmm
are you surprised that it hasn't really
caught on I what's the problem I you
know I think that people underestimate
how hard it is to make long-form
narrative work and how much you have to
spend time crafting it I mean I don't
mean to be a jerk about it but just cuz
you write a first draft if something
does not mean you need to shoot that and
expect it to be huge you have to have so
much care and especially who are you
calling out here no I'm just calling out
in general people people they're like
why did my Webster you get more views
and I'm like I can tell you 15,000
reasons yeah and most of it is because
the characters aren't real and the
situation is not fresh you know the
great thing about the web is that you
can break narrative you can do things
differently and I think that we have yet
to see how people creators do that
because it started from such a
user-generated sort of point of view was
people just picking up a camera and
going and that's awesome I love that but
it requires a million skills all put
together to make narrative work in a way
that is suspends disbelief you know when
people come to win on the guild set they
were like whoa I had no idea to take
took this many people to make it and
it's not like I bloat the set up it's
just like at a certain point everybody
needs to specialize a little bit in
order to make something really really
great like spooked you know it took five
months just to do post-production on
those episodes and not I'm not saying
you can't make something without that
but if you want to compete quote-unquote
with TV and make TV like things on it
requires a lot more budget and expertise
at least expertise in a lot of different
areas and crew and that's a lot to
wrangle so it gets you know you have to
just scale your vision I think you know
in the next five years a lot of people
will have grown up seeing the web as a
legitimate place to make art in a way
right versus like disposable
mm-hmm well yes so with the with the new
series spooked which just launched
yesterday when we were recording this
was the plan
so you've is half hour or you know
essentially sitcom length right so was
the planet always to put this on on
YouTube like was that the plan from
Fermi yeah it's part of it was part of
the funded channel initiative basically
so we needed to put it on YouTube
because they helped pay for it right um
but we actually released it also on Hulu
and you know I you know YouTube is a
really I'm not a native YouTube
personality you know and I admire people
who do it like you guys blow me away
because to me you are the epitome of
sort of melding creativity and artistry
with personality and I don't I drool II
you are the epitome of it to me
so kudos oh we're gonna I'm gonna put
that on a t-shirt you should it's a
really long sentence
I'm just gonna look the audience yeah
but you don't know say like you you
create things that should be created
that need to exist and and obviously
your individuality is in it and it's
thoughtful and that's what I love that
and that's why to me it lasts and it's
sticky and somebody will watch that a
year from now and it'll still be
relevant to their instrument cuz there's
a spark of artistry there and you know
doing their and like doing trying to do
TV like stuff on YouTube it's kind of an
uphill battle I'll admit it it's harder
it's not what the audience is used to
mourning or consuming and it's it's
challenging but to me you know that's
what I I make what I love and I love I
love long-form narrative
I love getting characters together and
just seeing them interact and I love and
to me if you there there's sort of a
snobbery in Hollywood to the whole
digital space and now everybody's moving
in but only to use it and I you know
it's just like how could I exploit that
network can I use to get people to
advertise for me just saying it is
another place for content it's a totally
different it's a different medium
exactly and I and I think if I have to
be the person to put something out there
that may not be you know you know the
hugest success but I'm still pushing the
envelope toward that because I truly
believe
the whole cable box is going to go away
and you're gonna get content of all
forms everywhere you go so I would like
to still be doing the things that I feel
like I do best which is something like
the guilders note and I and I you know
being on YouTube for the last two years
I never underestimated what it took to
become big on YouTube but you know being
in it I admire everybody so much more
any and I think that you know when
traditional Harley hood comes in and
thinks there's some kind of magic wand
to make the magic that the top youtubers
have I think they're completely clearly
fall flat on their face a lot yeah so
well it's interesting that because of
the success of the guild and everything
else that you're doing you become a
voice for these things that you're
speaking about now long-form content
narrative in this space particularly but
there's also the fact that you're
becoming a spokes person in the geek
community for women it's that's a thing
that's happening yeah I mean I it was
inadvertent its inadvertent but
something that I I feel I hope it
doesn't make my sellotape take myself
too seriously but it means a lot to me
when like a 18 year old comes up to me
and it's like hey I'm going in a
computer program because of you and the
guild and you you make it okay for me to
say that I love gaming and and I'm a
girl and I'm a girl yeah so it is a
byproduct that I'm very proud of and I
try not to let all the pressure of
expectation get to me well how do you do
it the fact that you know geek culture
has a strong reputation for objectifying
women you know when we see our female
superheroes they have to have all the
right assets and all the right places
and we've got you know got a word play
in it you know it's a it's a reputation
that I think there's plenty of evidence
for it's it's not undeserved reputation
a lot of times being a female what's it
like being a female in in in that world
where there's that kind of
objectification that happens and then
does that impact when you're creating
something are you thinking about okay I
am a female in this environment and
I'm going to go against the grain or you
know how does that honey how does that
play into it well first of all I don't
think that geek culture is necessarily
more misogynistic than any culture I
mean hip-hop culture
I mean true Hollywood culture like look
at like media culture who is on the
front of I mean I'm sorry Kim Kardashian
is probably a lovely girl but what she
represents to a little girl growing up
you know I I need to be like that to be
successful
those are not the tools that you want to
encourage somebody to gather for their
life because that is a very short window
and it's all reflective of what men want
from a woman you know that all those
it's fine I I you know it's fine if
you're doing it for the right reasons I
like to look attractive I love to have
you know have this image of myself but
if you're only doing it to have the
interest of men you're kind of that's
kind of your owned by men in a sense
right so I don't think necessarily
culture is the geek culture is more
biased toward women
I believe that geek culture originated
in a much more male centric world you
know it was more men who are the
outliers in the way who were on in all
these subjects earlier on and you know
that's reflected in sort of their the
way they see the world and now that
women have become a lot more vocal about
being part of the culture you know you
get people who are butting up against
two different perspectives on a culture
and that I think the great thing about
geek culture is that women do feel
empowered enough to say like no this is
my geek culture and I'm not going to
back down about it and I think that's
more empowered in a sense than other
mainstream sub pockets of genre like
mainstream media or whatever like it's
harder it's harder for women to stand up
and those other cultures that comprise
everything outside I mean like look at a
look at a toy aisle
you know the segregation is everywhere
yeah it's everywhere if you start
looking discriminately at every single
poster you see and say I'm gonna put a
guy in an outfit like that and and what
do I think of that if you start looking
at the world like that it transforms the
way you think you know you you realize
there are subliminal things that we
accept as culture around us that do
to make women the way steer women in one
direction and away from another that's
just what it is
I mean so what I what I appreciate about
geek culture is the advocacy of when you
know women being able to step out more
and also the impact that is having cuz
it does I love to see that there's
measure will impact because there's a
lot of vocal men and women about this
that they want it to be more inclusive
they want it to be more presented
representative and we're dealing in
worlds of fantasy there's no reason not
to be able to reinvent the way that we
live and you know most of the strong
female characters
yeah there's someone that some people
wearing tighty whities when they were
flying around and like a you know
there's there chainmail bikinis and
stuff but they're all are a lot of
precedents where you see women and
captains on starships and things like
that and you see that moreso in science
fiction and fantasy than you do in like
law and order and all that stuff you
know and use you speak into these things
publicly I want to talk about a recent
tweet that you did but personally do you
still experience or heavy experience
being objectified and what how how do
you deal with that personally maybe not
publicly well everyday if you're on the
internet you're objectified I mean if I
suite about spooked then you know
several hundred people will click on it
and as a producer but if I post a
picture of me in a pretty dress it's
like ten thousand people and that's men
and women who are reinforcing that so
that's just what the society is and it's
interesting because then you have the
choice well do I post the picture of me
and the pretty dresser or however you
put it yeah well of course I do
because I like being I mean I like being
in the pretty horse like I'm not like
I'm manipulating like hey I should post
a bikini shot today but I'm like I just
noticed the discrepancy with about what
people respond to I mean that's just
that's just way that the internet works
right that's why everybody loves healthy
selfies but you know as somebody who
puts themselves out there I mean I make
a video a week on my my personal channel
and I'm on geek and sundry every week
and you know when I cut all my hair off
for reasons you
you know it was it was quite hurtful
when I had people commenting oh well
I'll come back when you grow your hair
out I mean that happens every day about
my you know and I said and I'd notice
when we have girl hosts on our shows
exponential number of the comments are
more about their looks or than being
[ __ ] versus like a guy on the show and
it really just that's just what it is
and I try to push back a lot on that but
that's reality and you know and then
there's always like Twitter people just
harassing me right do you do you engage
you said you push back are these like
Twitter Wars or no no I block I'm such a
blocker
it's like popping pimples it's like walk
walk it's a fantastic I'm like I don't
need you you have the freedom of speech
to be the worst person ever I don't need
you in my world and thank you for
blocking and I've tended to be more
aggressive about blocking people on our
YouTube channels because I'm like I
don't need your hateful speech here this
is this is a place where I want people
to feel safe and feel like they're part
of a community not that you're gonna do
you know anti-feminist or homophobic
slurs there it's not just leave yeah
yeah I got new glasses and we made a
video where I was like listen I got new
glasses I know you're gonna be talking
about it let's just devote ten minutes
of a good mythical morning to discuss my
fashion choice because I knew it was
gonna it would the comments were just
gonna be about every opinion about it
yeah I haven't like it had to prepare
myself okay you're not gonna read the
comments but that's what you always read
them don't you of course I read what I
can but that's almost a ridiculous
example compared to what it is that
you're describing that women in this
medium go through a it's like me
changing glasses every single episode of
my show and every one about it everyone
caring about it instead of everything
that I cared about like what I'm saying
well I mean but appearance yeah parents
being so more weighted - whoa how a
woman is perceived and it's like you're
what you're it's fine I mean that's just
what we we judge people on appearance
and that's just who we are as humans but
when you're saying as a female you're
irrelevant your ear what you're saying
is irrelevant your your appearance is
the only reason I'm here
then that negates everything that I want
to say I mean that's that's that makes
me feel very devalued right your tweet
was it was a hashtag yes all women yeah
when a whole like tool box of trolls
well let me read it when a woman makes a
video most comments are about tearing
apart her looks or if they'd quote do
her with a man almost none hashtag yes
all women what were what was what was
the response there were a lot of
retweets I was a very popular tweet
tweet 5,000 favorites yeah that was good
I got a lot of I mean there were a lot
of people just basically trolling for
that hashtag to attack people using it
yeah and I got some very hateful speech
not as hateful as when I've done things
in the gaming world like the VGA Awards
or I see what else there was I had it
like someone there were a couple of
incidents in the past where somebody
said something really rude to me and
people called them out on it and saying
that I contributed to gaming and then
people just got very that was I wouldn't
actually hurt more when you're saying
that I'm just a booth babe I think
somebody mentioned I was a booth babe
and the guy later apologized yeah but he
later apologized which was cool but then
all these horrible people just piled on
and started attacking me and devaluing
my work and like I could take anything
said about my appearance I probably
sought it more than you have about my
appearance but when you attack my work
or my motivation for my work then you're
then I'm really sensitive about it
because I try to embody what I believe
and everything I do you know I've been
had so many offers to do TV shows or you
know go off and do much you know bigger
Hollywood quote-unquote sayings and I've
turned them all down because I believe
in the space so much and then when you
you know when I'm encountering things
like that where people just forget or
they devalue everything I've done it's
like well am i stupid
you know but you know you just block it
and move on and you see a really
complimentary tweet and it's like oh the
wound is healed you had to make a whole
blog post to back up your tweet yeah you
said I'm a person who always had has had
a ton of guy friends and the fact that
there are many social situations where
I'm
worth talking to as a person because I'm
not sexually available makes me so sad
for myself and for the friendships that
could be but will never happen because
to them I'm only there for a possible
hookup how would you read it out loud it
sounds harsh the fact that you said I I
wasn't going to be on social media today
then I tweeted this and now I'm writing
this whole blog post about the whole
thing you know and you have guy friends
is that I don't know I mean that's I
have a lot of guy friends actually but
I've been blown off from in more so
social situations because I let the
boyfriend wear the B word out and that
again is reflective of like well so I'm
not interested I mean I'm
I shouldn't be part of your world and
because I'm a woman I can't we can't
talk about the things that we look
mutually love together because I'm
somehow deceiving you if I'm not
sexually available like that was the
sort of the zeitgeist that I've got my
feelings hurt a lot when you when you
dive in in this way you know it's like
you said it's it's one thing obviously
these things are invited in your work
and the way that you portray female
characters and and just the worlds that
you create but then when you when you
kind of stick your hand into the
hornet's nest in this way on Twitter and
then you've got the blog post you're
obviously not just limiting it to your
work you're engaging in social media
which we all know how crazy things can
get do you regret that cars it's like no
this is part of how I am regret anything
I do I mean I'm not an impulsive person
I don't tend to vlog about things like
this you never regret anything you do
well no that's but I I I tend to I tend
to when I feel emotionally strong about
something I tend to follow that and I
feel like if I feel emotionally invested
in something I feel like that will
resonate with someone I'm like I feel
this strongly about this I know someone
else will agree with me and I would
rather you know I would rather talk
about something substantial that will
create a dialogue about something in a
way that doesn't condemn people but just
kind of is a talking point that's
important to me because as an artist if
you get back to who you are like you
here to create your here to reflect your
being and and every one of us is unique
and unless you're really always digging
and trying to redefine yourself and
express that individuality then you're
not gonna make great art and that's kind
of been a mission for me in the last
like six to eight months just to really
[Music]
reinterment say five years ago and
that's good because that means I'm
growing as a person do you think you
tried to kind of recreate that
atmosphere that led to the creation of
the guild you know you talked about how
you were you had money from the jobs
that you were doing but you were kind of
in this world where you didn't have you
weren't running the business that you're
running today were you trying to kind of
create almost a sabbatical type approach
to your life so that you could have that
time yeah those last like six to eight
months I have you know I did
when Wendy Cassandra first launched I
did a weekly show called the flog and I
love that show so much but it was a
weekly show and I had almost no help I
didn't know how to use a towel probably
didn't use a teleprompter like this was
me just like being enthusiastic about
the show and I loved it so much and I
had like one person who came in and shot
it and then other than that was me and
somebody who moved in from Andy Anna to
do it I didn't have any help and I
didn't know better I just didn't know
this world and I made some bad choices
personally that sort of burnt me out and
I think in doing a weekly show I was
pouring so much of my creativity into
there I had no well to go back to so
when I created guild season six the
theme of that was you know surviving
criticism and being an artist with all
the criticism happening that was
actually the theme of it because it's
the only thing I knew at that point
after geek and sundry had just launched
and after that I was like I have nothing
right now I don't know what to say I
don't know what I want to say as a
creator and I worry when I do little
things that I'm frittering away the
creativity needs to be hoarded up and in
order to make something bigger like the
guild I mean the guild came out of years
of work I spent six months just on the
characters I did so many drafts of that
script and after probably a year and a
half process I finally put a camera up
but it was so much work and it was never
good enough for me and I always was
digging like who is this person
who is this person so I get to the point
where it's a shorthand I'll know exactly
how they'll say a line or if I put two
people in the same exact situation these
characters are so distinct that they'll
talk completely differently I mean
that's when you create you know
something that can last 10 seasons or
something but it's not something in my
skill set that I can do overnight I'm
sure there are people in Hollywood can
do it you know very fast lately that's
not my process and you have to create
space exactly yes and I'm still creating
space so what are you most excited about
professionally that's coming up if you
can kind of paint a picture of what's
next you know as far as peak and sundry
goes we have some interesting things on
the horizon I wish I could say a bunch
of things but I'm in process on quite a
few things you want to like just mouth
it and then I will say it yeah but yeah
we have gabba gabba that's already that
names been taken we're gonna have a
bunch of really cool announcements at
Comic Con so if you're a fan of geek and
sundry come to comic-con and I'm
personally like working on three writing
projects and I basically gave myself a
year to write them so there's no
pressure and if the end I don't like it
I'm not gonna show it to anyone and that
is like it gives me comfort in a way
because I know that I'm creating
something for the right reasons first
it's like I gotta get something out
there people are gonna forget about you
well you know what you always have that
sense that trains gonna leave without
you yeah but it's fine because another
train will come along I mean really
honestly LA especially as bad about that
nobody's ever where they want to be in
this town and that sort of frantic sort
of I'm looking behind you to see if
there's something better happening it's
so inauthentic and false and kind of a
horrible way to be or at least fidgety
am i doing enough is it especially in
this medium - not in this town is there
something else is it should I be doing
something else on my time now there's
gonna be more strategic that's gonna be
the things gonna make all the difference
exactly all the time I guess I'm that
person I'm sorry I am that person too
and I literally have to tamp it down
because I understand having been here
for so long you guys have been you know
we started pretty much at the same time
there'll be another train yes there's
always another train and it'll be the
right train because literally a
single thing I've turned down in the
last year a better thing has come along
yeah or you can just get on one of those
things that's on the railroad tracks
that you pump up and down yourself
yes exactly the analogy further love it
make your own train and you certainly
already done that yeah okay now this is
an odd thing to bring up but it's it's
something that's in my mind it's a funny
conversation we had when we were hosting
that thing award where everyone was so
drunk I never thought they were did the
crowd talked the entire yeah the three
of us were reading off we were on stage
reading off teleprompters and in it it
was it we did great I wouldn't say I'll
never host anything again but certainly
I need to be creating I'm I'm I'm
putting a pause I'm putting a pin in
yeah right it was an opportunity with
you guys again I would be tempted but
but I remember a conversation that we
had backstage but it's kind of like
being in a war zone this type of thing
and when you want out next what's going
out next to like in front of the firing
squad but I remember one of the
conversations we had somehow we got onto
your first kiss with another woman was
so was on stage not on stage it was in
front of cameras you know so I wanted to
acknowledge wow that was it how do we
get there and I wanted to go back there
how do we get dream that out yeah as
long as we go back to it I don't care
how we did I just can you read tell me
that story no I mean no because I put a
few lessons and I think that's awesome
like that's great
and somehow sometimes I think that it's
Holly was way of getting a really smart
girl in there who doesn't have to be
perfect looking and they have to just be
like well she's just not sexually
sexually attracted to the guy but I
though I've been very lucky in that the
characters I've played who are lesbians
I'm not been that they've been really
well rounded awesome characters and I
play Charlie on supernatural and the
first time I ever the first time I ever
kissed another girl was the actress on
supernatural and she was like and did
you know it was it was in the script
actor she was like oh man I don't know
if I want to do this um because we don't
have to kiss when the cameras on us I'm
like yeah no I know that I don't this is
no I'm not getting all up in there like
this is not like playtime for me I'm
trying to be appropriate and then she
comes and she's like the camera rolls
and she's like all up in my grill so
that's was that's of story you're
talking about she seems like all tongue
it was it was aggressive more aggressive
than I would have thought and but she's
like an actor she committed so maybe I
should have committed more and I guess
my follow-up question was and still as
still is was there a sense in that
conversation ahead of time I was like
should we should we practice is there
something - no there's no practice
have you ever never done a love scene no
oh and so - no actually no link did a
kissing scene in one of our videos but
it was with his wife she insisted upon
being she has never been in a video and
then I come home and they're like listen
the script calls for me to make out with
a woman and she was like tell me when to
be there and and she said you can only
shoot the back of my head when I was
like well that's yeah it's fine just you
have to lean in and be the aggressor and
so just look at the amount of strategy
went into my conversation with my own
wife to make out on camera and if I had
to make out with a guy on camera it
seems like there'd be a lot of logistics
to work out ahead of I mean really it
was only like let's not kiss off-camera
I went a camera thought I was I'm like
yeah of course so that was it that was
the only negotiation happening but she
assumed that you would like to practice
I don't know what she was assumed I
think she was just a little bit nervous
and I was like yeah I would be might
imagine yeah I mean a nervous to kiss a
girl on camera and then if I had to kiss
a guy on camera be not gay yeah and that
would be even more like okay now there
it was fine it just it was lips they
were a little bit too soft that's all my
opinion of it was not in a bad way I was
just like this is softer than normal
right there normally callused and
Ernie's the only bristle bristles
so it was weird for her but it was
nothing for you it was just it was not
not weird I mean it was a novel I wish
I'd done it in college there you go okay
and so an you written a novel or made
out with a girl in college and you can't
you played a couple other lesbians and
then in the first episode of spooks
features a lesbian couple and you know
we got some great comments that were I
blocked everybody what was the strategy
there because obviously it's like I mean
there's one strategy which is like hey
let's start let's go episode 1 with a
lesbian couple because everybody will be
ended there yeah it was me you know
listen I mean doing scripted on YouTube
is as you know challenging
I always think not like let's start
lesbians in there but let's do something
that mainstream TV would not do that's
always in my mind if this feels too much
like TV then I know 100% that it's not
going to catch people's attention right
and our script literally we were trying
to find a guy to play Alison Haislip
spart we I was and I was so upset I was
like there's something wrong about this
there's something wrong about this it's
not special enough it's not special
enough and the director and I were like
well why can't it be a woman and then
once we said that I was like oh wow the
whole character arc where the dad not
liking them getting married means mean
something there was substance so we made
that artistic decision because there's
substance there for the for the
character the for the story arc of the
story versus like let's just do a stunt
that was never my intention it will
never be my intention and the fact that
we can represent a lesbian couple being
just people in an in a show that should
happen everywhere it's the same thing
with a guild like we should have Asians
and people of color not calling
attention to look I'm the I'm the person
of color
like that's how or on the smart girl
like it just should be and that's what I
feel is kind of false about TV when I
see it I see that it's sort of they're
pulling from the same cast of characters
over and over and the same kind of
actors in the same scenarios and I'm
like we're all seen it we've all seen it
being done probably better than this
like let's just go out of the box and
portrayal people that we don't aren't
used to seeing and that's why I
particularly love that casting choice
which literally
came like two days before we were
shooting because we couldn't find a guy
DJ and it all works out
yeah well listen we appreciate the time
that we've had together to pick your
brain well I don't know I was a little
rambling but I appreciate your having me
on this table has some of the people I
admire the most on it like Tobuscus and
jennamarbles and grace over there and
now you need to sign it I am totally
honored and there you have it our ear
biscuit with Felicia being so she was
off the radar and is now just kind of
coming back into the interfere of the
web she did a sabbatical like a
professor you know would this is the guy
thing that I've been termed that they
use professors sabbatical and they when
they take an extended leave but you know
I hear you know she talks about this
finding this creative time you know I'm
interested in that but I'm also just
interested in you know hobbies like
woodworking furniture building foam
sculpture if you're interested in
hairstyling you could get a hair styling
kit think of all the things that we
could do on a sabbatical and we want to
do it together yeah I do think that we
should when I shoot me 2k hey we're not
gonna do a sabbatical I can't even spell
sabbatical I don't think you can take
one unless you can spell it fall you can
look at but I will google it and then
that may be that I'll get me interested
sometimes you can spell a word you're so
bad at spelling words that you cannot
google it you ever happen like so you
can't even get spellcheck to recognize
it like you're like I can't even get
close enough that was me you trying to
spell silhouette I try to suppose
silhouette I'm like I can't get close
enough to have it tell me that I'm wrong
that's how bad I am but if we take a
sabbatical I do think it needs to be for
creative purposes it there needs to be
some applying or so I'm gonna create a
lot of stuff foam sculpture and
furniture no I think they arose I think
that we would write a lot more music
chest of drawers or Chester drawers as
you refer to them as yeah like it's like
it's an uncle I got an uncle named
Chester drawers write a lot of music
I'm down with that but but separately I
mean can't be on a sabbatical together
that's weird you're gonna be on my
sabbatical yeah
maybe we should take a sabbatical with
semi regular check-ins like maybe two
cabins in the woods separated by about a
mile so you had a walk but there's a
line of sight so we can communicate
about like our can phone with a string
between the two cans yeah that would
probably impede the creative process but
yeah we could do it separate I don't
care whatever I'll go to my own cabin I
don't even need I don't need a line of
sight I mean it's not we're not that
codependent are we I don't think so but
as long as I can string we'll reach let
Felicia know what you thought of her
your biscuit her twitter handle is
Felicia Day it has two eyes in it and it
has two A's in it has one e in it that's
how you spell it also remember you can
support the show by going over to iTunes
leaving a review or a rating can also
leave a comment on soundcloud some of
the plays you can listen to the podcast
let us know what you think about the
podcast hash tag hash Mahesh hatchback
oh man I need a sabbatical or else I'm
gonna keep saying things like hash tag
back your best kids hash bags a totally
different thing I'm not going no
handbags almost better
hash tag your biscuits sorry
[Music]
[Music]